[MUSIC PLAYING]
- So good afternoon, everybody.
I'm very glad to see here so
many friendly and familiar
faces.
Thank you for coming
here this hour.
It's really a great honor for
me to be here on the stage
and I would like to think the
Radcliffe Institute for giving
me this opportunity for
the amazing fellowship
program which I'm part of.
And to thank Dean Cohen
and Professor Vichniac,
Rebecca, Sharon, all the
Radcliffe staff working
tirelessly both in front
and behind the scenes
to make this all happen.
Thank you very much.
I guess I'm also the first
one to talk about science
in these series of
Radcliffe public talks
and I must say that I feel a
little bit nervous and excited
after the wonderful
lecture of Professor Brian
Greene that all of you
attended maybe two weeks ago.
And I think the bar is set so
unachievably high that it's
probably impossible to make.
His ability to explain
very complex notions
in modern physics and string
theory that probably requires
the most complicated
math that has ever
been invented in very
simple layman terms
is really extraordinary.
So I was actually, as Judy
mentioned, two years ago,
I was invited to speak at
the World Economic Forum
in all these events
that gathers all
the mighty people of the world.
And I prepared a
wonderful presentation
about the latest
and greatest stuff
that we're doing
in our research,
but their reaction was
oh, actually our audience,
maybe in the best case, would
read Scientific American.
So they want to hear a nice
story and see cool pictures.
And so I hope I have prepared
an interesting story for you
tonight.
Or actually, three stories--
one about the past, my
personal account how
I got interested and involved
in this field and basically
got into a career in research.
The present, the current,
state of the earth
and the cool technology
that exists today.
And maybe a bit more
ambitiously, and maybe a little
bit also more
arrogantly, the future.
Or at least what I believe
to be the future or at least
potentially interesting
and promising research
directions on which I will
be working during this year
here at Radcliffe and
of course, our intent
to show plenty of pictures.
And in fact, it's not
the case that there
is a saying that the picture
is worth a thousand words.
And if we look at the amount of
the information that our brain
receives from different senses,
most of it-- about 90%--
comes from vision.
And the site is arguably the
most important of our senses,
and we use it continuously
in our everyday life.
We start learning to recognize
visual objects, basically,
from age zero-- the moment
we open our eyes way
before we learn how to speak.
And therefore, we take
these amazing capability
of our own brain of
visual perception
almost for granted
without actually realizing
how complex the
process that is going
behind the scenes in our
brain that makes it work.
My main field of research
is computer vision-- a field
where we try to
give the machines
the remarkable capability to
see and understand and perceive
the world around it.
Anecdotally, the birth
of computer vision as we
know it is credited to a
summer project at the MIT
just next door here in
Cambridge in the 1960s.
And there, a group of
researchers-- three people,
unfortunately, two of them
are not with us anymore--
they got a television
camera that could
be connected to a computer.
And if you think of the
technology in the '60s,
that was super high technology.
They assigned graduate
students with the task
of making the
computer describe what
it sees basically, parse the
visual objects in the scene.
And though I'm told that
MIT students are very good,
probably among the
best in the world,
even they failed to
complete this project.
So it didn't work
well at the end.
Probably otherwise, I
wouldn't be standing here
to speak about computer vision.
And even 50 years
since, the problem is,
I would say, quite
far from being solved.
So speaking seriously, one
of the first applications
that computer vision
researchers considered
was to recognize human faces.
And for us, it's very
important, of course,
for social interactions
when we talk
to people we know from the
faces to whom we are talking.
And you can also think of other
applications like security
applications when
the computer needs
to know who is the
person in front of it.
The human face appears to
be very structured object.
We all have a nose, a
mouth, pair of eyes.
And what makes us
different from each other
is how these different
facial parts look like
and how they are related.
What are the spatial
relations between them.
So the first works
on facial recognition
tired to automatically detect
these features of the face
and compute their geometric
relations, in this way,
creating a kind of
geometric descriptor
that would able to
identify the individual.
And at the first glance, it
may sound like an easy task.
But the problem is that we
are looking at an image.
Basically, a two
dimensional image
that comes from a
projection of three
dimensional world by means of
a camera that mixes together
a lot of different
information-- the initial color
of the object, its reflected
properties, its geometry,
its position in space,
the way it is illuminated.
Basically, we get a single image
that has all this information
mixed together and extracting
different components
is a very challenging task.
So if you look at these
pictures of a human face,
it is even hard to tell
that that's the same person
so differently it
is illuminated.
And for a computer,
it would be very
hard to distinguish between what
constitutes a facial feature
and what is a kind
of false feature--
what comes from external
factors like light and shadow.
And that's why many
face recognition,
of the past at least,
that worked very well
in the lab in very
controlled conditions
failed miserably when taken
into outdoor environment.
Lighting is just one
of different factors
that can affect the
appearance of the face.
You can also think of, for
example, head orientation
or maybe even
facial expressions.
So talking about illumination,
probably the most famous
example of the jokes-- so
to say that light can play--
is this image taken by
the NASA Viking mission
on Mars in the '70s.
This bizarre
face-looking structure
baptized by the journalist
as the Martian Spinx,
or face on Mars, gave rise to
numerous conspiracy theories
and ideas about intelligent
extraterrestrial life.
But subsequent photos show that
it's just a rock formation that
appeared in this weird form
because of particularly
wacky illumination.
So if you were impatient to
get signs of intelligent life
on Mars, at least not that time.
It didn't happen.
Let me show you another example.
You can look at this drawing
and tell me if it frightens you.
Does it frighten you?
You certainly recall the
little Antoine de Saint-Exupery
posing this question, right?
And people replied, why should
anyone be frightened by a hat?
It's a hat.
However, of course,
what he meant
was not a hat but a huge snake.
A boa constrictor
digesting an elephant
that would look like this.
Again, this is another
example of how ambiguous
a two dimensional projection
of three dimensional objects
could be.
So since we humans we don't have
the ability to explicitly sense
depth, we just get
a rough idea of it
through our binocular vision
or other implicit cues
such as shading and shadows.
We attribute way more
importance to the appearance
than to the 3D geometry.
Let's do the
following experiment.
That's an image that
appeared in a book
that we wrote
about 10 years ago.
This is a 3D scan
of a human face.
You can see the three
dimensional surface.
Now imagine that we
had major make up
that would allow us to
draw anything on this face.
We can do it, of course, with
computer graphic tools using
texture-mapping techniques.
So if you were able
to paint something,
let's paint the face
of another person.
Let's paint the
face of George W.
Bush who was the President of
the United States at that time.
Or if you don't like for
some reason George W. Bush,
let's paint Osama bin Laden,
who was that number one wanted
terrorist at some point.
And it's exactly the same
three dimensional surface
just painted differently.
And we perceive it
as different people.
Whereas, if we could explicitly
sense the three dimensional
structure, if you will
could analyze the geometry,
we'll be able to tell
immediately that that's not
Bush or bin Laden.
It's just an imposter
that painted himself
in Bush or bin Laden's style.
So this 3D structure
is not affected
by makeup, illumination
or head orientation.
And it contains a lot of useful
information, potentially,
that could make face
recognition better.
So we looked into ways of
using 3D geometry to make
face recognition more reliable.
And this was 15 years ago.
I was still an
undergraduate student
at [INAUDIBLE] as Judy
mentioned in her introduction.
And this was one of my first
two years research projects
during my undergraduate
studies that I
would say now, to
a large extent,
has shaped my research
interest and also
the future academic career.
And maybe on a
more personal note,
also has created a wonderful
bond and friendship
with my former PhD advisor,
Professor [INAUDIBLE]
from the [INAUDIBLE].
Long friend and collaborator,
not only in size, but also
in commercial endeavors.
So in particular,
we're interested
in facial expressions because
our face is non rigid.
It can deform and the
deformations of the face
make the life of facial
recognition systems
that are based on these
measurements of distances
between facial
features very hard.
Talking about
distances on the face,
there are several ways
of measuring distances.
We can just take two
points and connect them
with a straight line.
This is what we call
the Euclidean distance.
And as I said, such distances
can change significantly
when the face
undergoes deformations
due to facial expressions.
Another option is to look at
the lengths of the shortest
curve connecting two points.
In technical jargon, this is
called the geodesic distances.
And we found out that such
distances undergo much less
variation, or
approximately invariant,
under facial expressions.
And now we can measure
geodesic distances on surfaces.
There are efficient numerical
algorithms to do it.
But we didn't want to use any of
landmarks such as eyes or nose
tip.
First, because it's hard
to reliably detect them.
And second, because there are
very few stable facial points
that you can detect on the
face, while many other parts
of the facial surface-- like
the forehead for example--
it's impossible to detect
anything meaningful there.
So basically, we end
up with a collection
of points, geodesic distances
measured between them.
And now we need to
compare them because we
want then to tell whether two
people are similar or not.
So it would be nice if
we would have some way
to represent these
distances in some space that
is convenient to work with.
For example, if we could use
a Euclidean space or, even
better, two dimensional
Euclidean space-- the plane.
And these kind of problems
arise in cartography.
Assume that you are given
a selection of cities
with distances between them.
And, of course, here we're
talking about geodesic distance
because when we travel
on earth, we don't
dig a tunnel under the ground.
We actually fly over
the spherical surface,
so it cannot be a straight line.
It must be a geodesic distance.
For example, here
the geodesic distance
between San Francisco and New
York would be 2,500 miles.
So we would like
to create a plane
or map of this vertical
surface of the Earth, such
that the Euclidean distances
between these cities
are basically represented by
Euclidean distances on the map
that you can measure
with a ruler.
And these new
distances are equal
to the original geodesic ones.
And this is called an
isometric embedding
where the term "isometric" means
distance preserving in Greek.
So how should we do such a map?
If you ask a
mathematician, you know
that mathematicians are
especially annoying type
of people.
And when you ask them
how to do something,
they will not tell
you the answer,
they will ask you whether
it's at all possible.
So is it possible to
create such a map?
And is it indeed possible to
find an isometric embedding
of a curved surface--
for example, they've
given the sphere--
into the plate?
And that's out of
this question which
has to do with another
apparently unrelated question.
Is the circle perimeter
always equal to 2 pi r?
So it sounds like
a silly question.
This is a formula we
all learned in school.
And indeed, it has been an
undisputed fact in geometry
since the ancient Greeks.
And they took about 2,000 years
until Reimann and Lobachevsky
formulated what we call
today non-Euclidean geometry.
It's where circles can be
longer or shorter than flat ones
or, maybe more famously, whether
parallel lines can intersect
or not.
So the degree to
which the perimeter
of a circle on a surface is
different from the school
formula 2pir is
called curvature.
And I'm not as good
as Brian Greene
in visualizing 11 dimensional
Calabi-Yau manifolds.
Fortunately, we're talking here
about two dimensional manifolds
and I brought some paper models.
So I will show you what
curvature means on paper.
So this is a flat circle, right?
So basically, here
you can see it
has radius, r, and the perimeter
is equal exactly to 2 pi r.
Now if I wanted to create
positively curved surface,
by this definition,
I need to create what
is called the perimeter defect.
I need to make the
perimeter shorter.
And by making the perimeter
shorter, I get curvature.
Luckily, around this point, the
surface looks like a sphere.
So it's positively curved.
If you want to make a
negatively curved surface,
you need to actually
increase the perimeter
and you get a surface that
looks like a [INAUDIBLE]..
In geometric terms, this is
called a hyperbolic surface.
So this is curvature.
It's really a fundamental
concept in geometry
that has many definitions.
For example, you can also
consider the definition
of the curvature by just
taking a piece of paper,
bending it, and looking at
different directions of curves
that pass for a point.
And the smallest and
the largest curvature,
what are called the principal
curvature, as their product
defines exactly the same
notion that we've seen before.
This notion of
curvature dates back
to Karl Friedrich Gauss,
probably the most prominent
mathematician that
has ever lived.
And when he wrote
down the expression
for the curvature that
bears his name today--
the Gaussian curvature-- he
was surprised to find out
that it can be
expressed entirely
in terms of the intrinsic
structure of the surface, what
we call the metric.
Meaning that if we deform the
surface without stretching
or tearing it, such
deformation will not
change the curvature
of the surface.
And again, piece of
paper is a good model.
You can bend it, but
you cannot stretch it.
It is not elastic.
Gauss was so surprised
with his observation
that he named the
result-- and he
was writing in Latin--
theorema egregium
or the remarkable theorem.
And Gauss was not only a
great mathematician, but also
a very modest man.
And if he thought of
something as remarkable,
it must really be.
And of course, you
may think, this
is just some weird
geometric idea.
Why on earth should you care?
Well, I believe that you should.
It appears that curvature
plays a fundamental role
in the modern description
of our universe
Einstein's general relativity
theory models gravitation
by curvature of the space-time.
It is slightly more complicated
because the spaces there
are higher dimensional, but
the basic idea is the same.
And again, here I cannot refrain
from referring to the lecture
of Professor Greene where he
masterfully showed the meaning
of these concepts.
But not only on
cosmic scales do you
encounter the notion of
curvature and manifestation
of the remarkable
theorem of Gauss,
but in much more
prosaic situations when,
for example, you eat pizza.
So again, I have
here a paper model.
And I beg the forgiveness
of my Italian wife
for calling this piece
of paper a pizza.
Think of it as playing
with zero curvature.
So when you grab
a piece of pizza,
you instinctively tend
to bend it like, right?
By bending it like this,
you create here a direction
in which it is curved.
Now remember that the
Gaussian curvature
is defined as product
of principle curvature.
So it has a curvature
here that is non-zero,
so you must create
a reach, a direction
in which the curvature
would be zero-- basically,
a straight line.
And this gives rigidity
to this piece of pizza
that prevents the topping
from falling and spotting
your shirt or pants.
And of course, this is just
a mathematical abstraction,
so in practice, real pizza
might have some elasticity.
So if disaster happens sometime,
don't blame it on Gauss.
And of course, the
remarkable theorem
had an impact in cartography
which brings us back
to our original question.
So now you know the
answer that the sphere
has constant positive
curvature and the plane
has zero curvature.
So they cannot be
isometric and, even worse,
by different arguments, usually
such isometric embedding v will
not be possible even to
Euclidean spaces of higher
dimension.
So what we can
still do is to find
representation that distorts
the distances the least.
So it will not be
a true isometric,
it will be
approximate isometric.
In this way, we can get the
Euclidean representation
of the face that allows to
undo the facial expressions.
And this way, making the
comparison of two facial
surfaces much easier.
During my masters
and PhD studies,
I worked on ways to efficiently
compute such minimal distortion
embeddings and
their applications
to problems in computer
vision and computer graphics,
in particular analysis of
deformable three-dimensional
objects.
And we also built a
face recognition system.
It was one of the first
3D face recognition
systems that also
allowed to cope
with facial
expressions, which is
one of the difficult
problems in this domain, that
was based exactly on
these geometric ideas.
And here we can see a
screenshot from these systems.
again, that was many years ago.
That shows the
recognition process--
the creation of these
four-dimensional Euclidean
representation.
And this, as Judy mentioned,
was joint work with my brother
who is also a
computer scientist.
He works in Israel and he works
exactly in the same field.
We've published a lot
of papers together.
And it's been a successful
collaboration already 37 years.
And again, as Judy
mentioned, what
makes the story especially
interesting and curious
that my brother and I
are identical twins.
And this is a composite
portrait of us from that period.
So you can see my picture on
the left in this portrait.
No actually, I'm on the right.
Sorry.
This is yet another proof
that we looked similar
and we are still similar,
but of course there
are some differences
in geometric structure
of our faces.
The 3D geometry
of our face is not
totally under genetic control.
So our system was
apparently able to detect
these differences
and tell us apart.
And the media
picked up this story
of face recognition
system able to distinguish
between identical twins.
This way I got my
15 minutes of glory.
Our research was featured on
CNN with quite an improbable
title "Twins Rock Face
Recognition Puzzle."
And of course, we
tried our system
on other pairs of twins--
identical twins- also
quite successfully.
So this looked like
a cool technology
and we tried to
commercialize it.
That was a period of booms
of start-ups in Israel.
In all these startup
nations, everybody
was trying to make
money out of technology.
So we thought why not to
try, but quickly found out,
to our great disappointment,
that there was really
no market for it, or at least
there was no market for it
15 years ago.
And one of the reasons is
being three-dimensional face
recognition system requires
a three-dimensional input--
a three-dimensional scanner.
And 15 years ago,
if you wanted to buy
three-dimensional
scanner, you would just
have a handful of devices
that you could really count
on the fingers of one hand.
And most of them
would look like this.
It's a big box of the
size weighing probably
several kilograms and
it costs like a new car.
So definitely a showstopper
for any serious commercial
application.
And in fact, the 3D
sensor at the time
were so prohibitively expensive
that for our 3D facing
commission system, we had
to develop our own 3D sensor
and you can see it
here in this picture.
It was a structured
light sensor.
We used a digital
slide projector
to illuminate the face with
a sequence of patterns that--
captured by digital camera--
allowed to infer the 3D
structure of the face.
I remind you this was
15 years ago in 2002.
The year when the
movie "Minority Report"
hit the screens and for those
of you who have not seen it--
just one second spoiler--
it's a dystopian vision
of how our world might
look like in 2050.
And one of the most famous
scenes in this movie
is where Tom Cruise
uses his hand gestures
to manipulate virtual objects
on a huge holographic screen--
a vision of how we
might be interacting
with our future intelligence
machines in 50 years from now.
And in fact, the idea of
gesture-based interfaces
has been around for a while.
An interface like this that
would be based only on vision
requires the ability
to recognize and track
different parts of
the human hand, which
is a difficult problem because
our hand is a 3D object
and because of two
dimensional projection,
there are occlusions and
ambiguities so it's not easy.
Apparently, the creators
of "Minority Report"
were so skeptical about the
ability of computer vision
researchers to solve
this hand tracking
problem 50 years from now
in the very distant future
that they equipped Tom Cruise
with these light gloves
that you can see in
this movie scene where--
which, of course,
makes the life of hand
tracking much easier than
tracking simply bare hands.
So at least this part
of "Minority Report"
remains science fiction for
a very brief moment of time.
I hope the rest remains
science fiction forever.
In the matter of a
few years, Microsoft
released the highly
successful Kinect product.
It was a plug-in for their
Xbox gaming consoles that
allowed users to control
their games with bare hands
and gestures.
No gloves were required.
So it was even better
than envisioned
in "Minority Report."
And this ability
was made possible
by a novel 3D sensor
that was developed
by an Israeli company
called PrimeSense that
projected invisible infrared
light pattern on the objects
in front of it, and by simple
triangulation techniques
recovered the geometric
structure that was
accurate to a few millimeters.
And this gave a lot
more useful information
than standard two
dimensional image
because in 3D, the hand tracking
becomes much easier to solve
many of the ambiguities.
Microsoft, using
this 3D information,
we're able to use simple
computer vision and machine
learning techniques to do
efficient hand tracking.
So Kinect was by all means
a revolutionary product,
the first of its kind.
And at that point,
we again returned
to our old ideas of
trying to make the 3D face
recognition into a
commercial product,
but it became very quickly
apparent that the sensor itself
is much more interesting than
the particular application
of 3D face recognition.
The investors were
betting big time
on the future of 3D sensors.
Kinect, however
revolutionary it was,
was still large and clunky.
It required an external power
supply so you cannot simply put
such a device into a
mobile laptop, tablet,
or even cellular phone.
And we thought
that we could make
a much more cheaper device.
So it became a startup called
Invision based in Israel.
And in 2012, we were
acquired by Intel.
And somehow surprisingly,
even though it
was pretty dramatic
moment in life for me
and for my colleagues,
I don't have
any pictures from that moment.
Just this picture where the logo
of Invision on the office door
is replaced by the
logo for Intel.
And of course, it took
another several years
and the huge effort of
many teams inside Intel
before it became a
commercial product.
Actually, the first 3D
camera that could be mass
manufactured into
the form factor
that would allow to fit
it into mobile devices--
our technology got
the name Real Sense
and it was presented
by the Intel CEO
at the Consumer Electronics
Show in Las Vegas
in the beginning of 2015.
So I have here one of the
first samples of the camera
from a few years back.
So you can see that it's
a tiny, thin device that
easily goes into
[INAUDIBLE] left of display.
And for the launch
of the product,
Intel shot this
funny commercial that
was aired on Christmas, 2014.
For those of you who are fans
of the "Big Bang Theory,"
you can recognize the character.
- What's that?
Wow!
Hello, humans.
Focus on me.
- Focus on the guard.
Don't tell anyone what
you've seen in here.
- Have you seen what's in there?
- They have Intel.
This is where it all changes.
- So first of all, the Intel
lab doesn't look like this
obviously.
And here it says coming soon.
Of course now it is
a successful product
with several generations
and multiple millions
of units shipped worldwide.
And so if Kinect made
3D sensing affordable,
RealSense allowed to
make it ubiquitous,
and today, you can have a
3D sensor in your laptop
or tablet.
And this opens the door to
many interesting and important
applications.
Let me show just one example
of an application developed
by a Swiss company
called FaceShift.
- He name's Mandy.
The profile says 6'4",
good with an axe,
and likes the music
of Lana Del Rey.
Sultry, sexy, and when
necessary, extremely violent.
- So what you see here is a
computer graphics character
that is animated in real time
by a human actor that performs
in front of a 3D sensor.
And this kind of technology
is called motion capture.
Nowadays, it's widely-used
by Hollywood studios
to produce special effects
in movies like "Avatar."
But a typical motion capture
setup as big as this room
would cost millions of
dollars and requires to places
special markers on the
face and other body
parts of the actor,
while FaceShift did it
without any markers.
They marketed it as
markerless motion capture
and could do
practically the same
with just a small 3D sensor
that costs maybe $20 or $30.
So it was really remarkable.
FaceShift was acquired
by Apple two years ago.
And if you've seen the
presentation of the new iPhone
10 a few weeks ago,
Apple has really taken it
to completely next level.
There are emoji-animated
emoticons are, presumably
at least, powered by the
FaceShift technology.
And the piece of hardware
that enables this capability
is a tiny 3D sensor
that is built
into the phone, what Apple
calls the TrueDepth camera.
And again, Apple also acquired
PrimeSense that provided that
technology for the first version
of Microsoft Kinect and again,
presumably-- nobody really knows
except for people that work
at Apple that build these
products what exactly they do--
but presumably, that's a
very miniaturized version
of the same technology
that powered Kinect.
And you could also notice that
the new iPhone 10 abandoned
the fingerprint scanner
and instead they
do face recognition in
order to unlock the phone.
So interestingly, and maybe
a little bit ironically,
brings us back to the
good old face recognition
problem from which we started.
And now a lot of
things have changed.
Until the past five years,
the predominant way face
recognition-- but in general, I
would say most of the problems
in computer vision--
were approached was by designing
so-called feature descriptors--
a smart and carefully
engineered way
of capturing the local
content of an image.
For example, computing
histograms of local derivatives
or image gradients.
And some of these descriptors
had become extremely popular,
for example the paper describing
the famous [INAUDIBLE]
descriptor is arguably
one of the most
cited papers, not only
in computer vision,
but in the field
of computer science
with over 40,000 citations.
I checked Google Scholar
just a few days ago.
So the problem though with
such hand-crafted features
is that it's very hard to
decide a priori what constitutes
meaningful information and
what is the result of noise
or external factors such
as different illumination.
A paradigm shift that happened
recently in computer vision is
instead of trying to engineer
a local descriptor basically
hand-crafted by determining
what makes a good feature,
let's assume that we have a
template that we can pass over
the image and detect if it
correlates well with image
content depending on the
application for example,
if we're looking for--
human eyes or etc.
And we can use many such
templates, basically
a bank of filters, which
are combined together
through some nonlinear function.
And we can repeat this
process several times
applying filters to the output
of the previous layer again
and again.
And the key here is that you can
use these filters more or less
the way you want.
Basically, there is
no prior assumption
about how they look like.
The only thing that you care
is to select these filters
in a way that will
make your final goal,
your task work the best.
In this case, for example,
tell apart different people.
And it turns out
that in applications
like this in image analysis and
face recognition, the filters
that will be learned in the
first layers of the system
will be very simple
visual features,
oriented edges, corners.
Features in the
second layer will
capture more complicated
structures such as eyes
or noses, and in
the very deep layers
you will find units
that may be activated
by just that specific face
of that specific person.
You know that among
neuroscientists there
is a joke about the
grandmother neuron--
a hypothetical,
imaginary brain cell that
is activated when you see just
the face of your grandmother.
And the reference
to neurons in brain
here is not the case because
such systems are called
artificial neural networks.
And this particular
architecture that I described
is a convolutional
neural network
and they originated
as simplified
mathematical descriptions
of the human brain.
And the most important advantage
of artificial neural networks
is that they can
learn from data.
And roughly speaking, if we
cannot build an axiomatic model
of what makes a face
look like a face,
we can get many examples of
faces and, in particular,
faces of similar people
versus different people,
and we can train a neural
network to tell them apart.
in fact, artificial neural
networks are not new at all.
The first works in
this domain date back
to the '50s and the '60s
of the past century,
mainly by neuroscientists
attempting to model
how the human brain learns.
And in particular, the
convolutional neural network
that I showed in my example
was invented in the '80s
by Yann LeCun who is currently
the director of AI research
at Facebook.
But only recently the
computational power
of modern processors has
become sufficient to make
it possible to design very deep
and complex neural networks
that can adequately model the
complexity of visual objects.
So only recently, the
computational power
of modern processors have
become sufficient to make
sufficiently complex
models that can adequately
cope with the task of
visual object recognition.
We also have efficient methods
to train such networks and we
also-- probably that's
the most important part--
we also have very
large collections
of images on which these
networks can train.
And neural networks
in these settings
what is called
supervised learning
are very hungry for data.
And in order to learn
to recognize images,
they literally require millions
of examples to learn from.
So the convergence of
these three trends--
the computational power,
the efficient architectures
and methods, and also the
availability of big data,
and last but not least, the
persistence of a few research
teams in the world that
continued working on these
methods for the dark ages of
AI where neural networks became
almost a bad word and
extremely unpopular--
so people willing to risk
their academic career to push
for these ideas--
all has led to the
breakthrough or a household
name, a phenomenon that we
called today deep learning.
And I'm sure that you have
heard about deep learning
in the past couple of years.
Even if not, it is
very likely that you
are deep neural networks even
without being aware of it.
For example, the Siri voice
recognition in your iPhone
or if you have a Tesla car,
the autopilot feature--
they all are based
on deep learning.
In particular in the
field of computer vision,
deep learning had a
groundbreaking effect
amounting to a little
revolution that nearly wiped out
previous approaches in a
matter of just five years.
And I must admit that somehow
I have pity for the fact
that what turns out
to work the best
are brute force
methods and black box,
because we don't
really understand
how these neural networks
work and why they work.
These are now the best methods.
And especially when dealing
with geometry with 3D objects,
we have a lot of understanding
how geometry works.
We have very beautiful
differential geometric models,
and throwing these models
away is really a pity.
So the question
is can we combine
the best of these two worlds?
Can we treat the data correctly
from the geometric perspective,
but also take advantage
of the powerful tools
available today in the
field of machine learning?
Or can we build
some prior knowledge
or reasonable geometric
model of our data
into the neural
network architecture
and learn only what doesn't
fit well into this model?
This is what we call
geometric deep learning.
It's a new trend
in machine learning
that is followed by
several research groups.
Basically, it's an
attempt to generalize
successful deep
learning methods to data
that has non-euclidean
underlying structure.
One of the main
challenges in generalizing
deep neural networks to
geometric non-Euclidean
structures is that we need
to reinvent all the building
blocks of neural networks.
For example, take the
convolution operation
that is used in convolutional
neural networks.
In an image, we can simply slide
a template across the image,
right?
The way it works is you
take a block of pixels,
you multiply it by template,
you sum up the results
and that's the output
of the convolution.
Then you move your
template to a new location.
So on the surface,
because of the curvature,
the local structure
of the surface
will differ at different
points as you can see here.
So this notion of page changes
throughout the surface,
or in technical terms, we don't
have shift invariance which
determines a lot of important
characteristics of convolution
in the Euclidean setting.
So there are several
ways of defining
filtering operations that
look like convolutions
on non-Euclidean spaces.
The one I would
like to show here
is based on modeling heat
propagation on surfaces.
The first systematic
study of heat
was done by Joseph Fourier,
French mathematician, actually
a contemporary of Gauss.
And besides being a
talented mathematician,
he was also a gifted
administrator and this cost
Fourier a part of
his scientific career
as he received from Napoleon
an offer that he could not
refuse--
an appointment as the prefect
of the city of Grenoble.
And in his work "Analytic
Theory of Heat,"
he formulated some of the
very basic equations that
are taught today in all
mathematical physics
courses throughout the world.
And also introduce
the basics of what
we call today free analysis.
So his book was published
almost 200 years ago,
so we are using
pretty old stuff here.
This is the partial
differential equation
that governs the heat
diffusion on surfaces.
It's exactly the same equation
Fourier derived in his work.
The only difference here is that
the operators on the right hand
side are defined
intrinsically on the surface.
We call this equation isotropic
because the speed of the heat
propagation on the
surface here is
assumed to be constant and
uniform in every direction
in every point.
So the way of thinking of it is
that you pierce this poor horse
with an infinitely hot
needle at the point,
and then you allow as
time goes for the heat
to spread throughout
the entire surface.
And basically, the
heat propagation
follows the structure
of the surface.
In particular, it
depends on the curvature.
And the great thing
about this equation
is that it is intrinsic
so the result will not
change no matter how we
deform this horse shape as
long as the deformations remain
isometric, or in other words,
they don't stretch or they
don't tear the surface.
So far, we assumed that the heat
flows equally fast everywhere.
We can consider a more
complicated and isotropic heat
diffusion where the heat
propagation speed depends
on position and direction.
It is modeled if you're
interested in math,
by this matrix A in the right
hand side of the equation.
And in this example, you can
see that the heat flows faster
in the horizontal direction.
Actually the term horizontal
here is totally appropriate
because the diffusion process
is intrinsic and defined
on the surface itself.
So on the surface, you can talk
only about local directions
with respect to some local
system of coordinates.
we can design an
isotropic heat diffusion
that flows in a
prescribed direction,
and controlling the direction of
the diffusion and the diffusion
time--
the size of this heat
blob on the surface--
we can construct the locals
system of coordinates that
is intrinsic by definition.
And these coordinates can be
used to define a local page
and using which you
can define operations
similar to the
template matching we've
seen in convolutional
neural networks.
We used these and
similar constructions
to develop the first deep neural
networks in manifolds where
the architecture
counts correctly
for the structure of the
underlying geometric object
and has a built-in
invariance to deformation.
And this is
particularly important
when dealing with deformable
3D shapes like our body.
The deformations
of the human body
can be approximated
reasonably well as isometries,
but where they deviate
from this model,
we can compensate by learning.
So in other words, we just
learn what cannot be modeled
axiomatically and as a result,
end up with way simpler network
that requires
orders of magnitude,
less parameters than traditional
Euclidean architectures,
and also require much
less data to train.
So it all reduces to
much simpler things.
When we applied intrinsic
convolutional neural networks
to learn correspondence
between deformable shapes,
this is one of the
cornerstone problems
in many applications in
computer vision and graphics.
For example, it's a crucial
step in the markerless motion
capture that I mentioned before.
Here, you can see a few
examples of correspondence
between human shapes visualized
by color texture, independent
of the poles and
individual characteristics
of the human body.
Geometric deep
learning currently
holds the record of the best
quality 3D correspondence
on several standard benchmarks.
If so far we are
talking about surfaces
as examples of
geometric objects,
there are other
structures that can
be approached by geometric
deep learning methods,
such as graphs and networks.
And in the remaining
time, I would
like to show a few results,
and maybe, mostly ideas
and promising research
directions in that regard.
In social networks are
probably the first example
that comes to my mind.
Mathematically
speaking, it's a graph
where the nodes or the vertices
represent users and the edges
represent the social relations.
So you mentioned that we are
given a social graph, say
from Facebook, and
we have information
about the users such as
their gender, age, education,
background, religion, whatever.
And assume that
for some users, we
know how they voted in
the recent elections.
So geometric deep learning
on the social graph
can use this data to predict
whether a particular user voted
for Clinton or for Trump
from the information
of his friends and
their voting patterns
and the structure of the graph.
So in a sense, the
saying, tell me
who your friends are and I will
tell you who you are has never
been more true.
Here's another application.
I'm sure that many of you
watch movies on Netflix.
An important problem
for Netflix is
how to recommend new movies to
users predicting whether they
might like them or not.
And this is called
recommendation system
and you can imagine what kind
of commercial value or impact
it might have for online
retail platforms such as Amazon
or Google.
10 years ago, Netflix even
announced the competition
bearing a $1 million prize for
a search team that would improve
on their prediction results.
So assume that users can give
scores to movies on a scale
from 1 to 10.
Mathematically, we can think
of them as a huge matrix.
Netflix has tens of millions
of users and hundreds
of thousands of movie titles.
And the matrix is only
very, very sparsely sampled
because a single person
can see that many movies
in his or her lifetime.
So the recommendation
problem consists
of predicting and filling in the
missing values of this matrix.
Standard approaches use
algebraic techniques
trying to find some low
dimensional model that
explains the data,
basically by minimizing
what is called matrix
rank, or more correctly,
a convex proxy of the rank,
usually the [INAUDIBLE]..
Now assume that we know the
relations between the users.
For example, in the form of the
social network that we've seen
before, we can use the geometric
deep learning to learn how
to aggregate scores of the
users social neighborhood--
friends and friends of friends--
in order to predict whether
he or she will like a movie
or not.
And we're able to show a
significant improvement
over standard approaches using
these type of techniques.
So geometric deep learning
seems to have also
big promise for recommender
systems as well.
The final example I
would like to mention
is from the domain of chemistry
and this is work actually done
here at Harvard.
One of the hard problems
in material or drug design
is that you need to
search over a huge space
of potential
candidates before you
discover that right
molecule that does the job.
And today, this is still done
either by very complicated
simulation on supercomputers--
molecular dynamics--
or by experiment in the lab.
And if you can think
of molecules as graphs
where the nodes model atoms
and edges are chemical bonds,
we can employ
geometric deep learning
for future
rescreening a molecule
to determine whether it
has certain properties.
For example, in
drug design, this
could be efficiency
against certain pathogen
or its toxicity.
So these methods
have already been
tested in several real
life applications,
for example, for the
design of new materials.
And the promise is
huge, potentially
cutting times of molecular
discovery and design
by orders of magnitude.
So in general, graphs appear
to be a very natural model
of relation or interaction
between different objects
or things.
Graphs can model relations
between different regions
in the human brain in
functional magnetic resonance
imaging in order to better
understand how the brain works
or how to diagnose and
cure neurological diseases,
or interactions between
particles in a large Hadron
Collider where energetic beams
of protons are banged together.
And the hope is to discover
new physics or maybe
spatial relations, spatial
structures of proteins
that constituents the cells
of every living thing.
And my hope is that harnessing
the power of machine
learning and combining it with
meaningful geometric structures
for this kind of data and
these kinds of problems
would bringing both quantitative
and qualitative breakthroughs.
And perhaps we'll see some new
exciting science and technology
coming out of this research.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]